at new york's american museum of natural
history we are past the roosevelt atrium
through the frick building and tucked
away behind drawers of bones dr jack
sang is hard at work
he's a dog guy i have worked on dog
evolution dog fossil for about 10 years
jack's the man when it comes to dog
evolution and he says dogs might have a
shot at outliving us all
humans have been evolving for roughly 3
million years but dogs have been around
way longer and that history goes all the
way back 40 million years
it hasn't been easy they've dealt with
warming cooling the ice age
to determine how dogs are going to fare
as the world changes you have to start
in the past because dogs are
evolutionary marvels
the first dogs weren't really dogs as we
know them today they were tree dwellers
and really small
they changed to survive their legs
lengthened so they could run longer
distances and they grew a lot
during the ice age the big wolves
weighed around 140 pounds
but it's their teeth that are really the
key to their survival
their teeth were getting stronger to
deal with the larger bones and the grip
that they might get in their mouth when
they're hunting
what he's saying is that it's biological
that dogs are eating machines
think of their teeth as a basic
blueprint that goes back 40 million
years and can be adapted to any kind of
environmental change
the teeth in the back crush bone those
teeth in the middle are for cutting and
the front teeth are for puncturing
what's more dog's teeth have reinforced
surfaces
that means their teeth will stay intact
whether they're eating large bones or
chewing up carcasses
it also means dogs don't really need us
they'll be able to survive even if we're
no longer around to feed them because
they can eat pretty much anything that
comes their way
if we do go and there are left i'm sure
they will adapt to whatever environment
that comes their way
you